today we're going to refresh your memory
on the cyberpunk 2077 expansion rumors
before the future of the game is
officially revealed next week
cd projekt red says that it will reveal
what's next for cyberpunk 2077 in a live
stream next week alongside its game the
company will also share some new
information on the cyberpunk edgerunner
series coming to netflix soon this new
night city episode will be streamed at 8
am pacific time 11am eastern on
september 6th but while we wait for that
let's go over the story details for the
upcoming expansion that appeared to have
leaked online back in may of this year
according to vgc which saw the leaked
files and first reported on them
hundreds of lines of dialogue spelling
out most of the events and characters of
the expansion appeared online the
dialogue points to a character named
songbird who is datamined in cyberpunk
2077 being the focus of the dlc the
expansion will reportedly take players
to the combat zone and sports dome which
were previously inaccessible spots
across cyberpunk 2077 setting night city
while the side missions seem to mostly
contain placeholder text enough of the
dialogue throughout shows that johnny
silverhand an ai of a rockstar played by
keanu reeves may have a more diminished
presence in the expansion though it's
unknown exactly why that may be the case
instead songbird seems to be this
expansion's driving force and may serve
as players new guide as they're taken
through its reported seven main missions
various side missions and world
encounters interestingly the league also
suggested that completion of the dlc may
alter some of the dialogue from the
game's ending since the events of the
expansion are reportedly mentioned by
characters in the leaked files version
of the ending but ok let's take a sharp
turn to the left and talk about game
pass because the friends and family
bundle has been officially confirmed by
microsoft u.s pricing details or a
global rollout date has not yet been
revealed but the xbox game pass friends
and family plan works out to roughly
ten dollars more than the current solo
plan that's priced at fifteen dollars
the plan costs 22 euros and forty nine
thousand nine hundred cop respectively
converting a current game pass ultimate
membership will have its time converted
to reflect the value of the friends and
family plan microsoft also mentioned
that subscribers can only be a member of
one group at a time and that the primary
account holder can invite up to four
people at a time with a maximum of 8
people who accept to join your account
per year only the primary account holder
can share their game pass benefits with
home sharing and group members cannot
share with other accounts on their
console another limitation to take note
of is xbox game pass friends and family
plan can only be shared with people who
live in your same region or country
comment down below who you plan on
sharing game pass with and how excited
you are for next week's cyberpunk news